[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا اهلا وسهلا بكم احرزت اذا
المقاومه اليمنيه والجيش الوطني تقدما
باتجاه معسكر فرضه هم المطل على البوابه
الشرقيه للعاصمه اليمنيه صنعاء نتوق مع
هذا الخبر لنناقش في محورين ما الذي يعنيه
هذا التقدم الجديد في فرضت ن بالنسبه
للمقاومه اليمنيه والجيش
الوطني وما هو تاثير هذا التقدم على
القرار الاستراتيجي المتعلق بمعركه
[موسيقى]
صنعاء تقدم جديد تحرزه المقاومه اليمنيه
والجيش الوطني في منطقه منطقه فرضه نهم
فقد قال قاده ميدانيون عسكريون ان هذه
القوات اقتحمت معسكر فرضه نهم وكانت
المقاومه قد اعلنت انها فرضت على مدى
الايام الماضيه حصارا على المعسكر كما شهد
محيطه اشتباكات بين المقاومه والجيش
والحوثيين وتكتسب هذه المعارك اهميه
استراتيجيه فمنطقه فرضه نهم هي البوابه
الشرقيه للعاصمه ميه صنعاء نتابع تقرير
زياد بركات ثم نفتح النقاش مع
ضيوفنا ثمه ما هو استراتيجي هنا الاقتراب
من صنعاء وتحديدا من غلافها او ما يعرف
بحزامها القبليه بسرعه وبشكل مفاجئ اقتحمت
قوات الجيش الوطني والمقاومه الشعبيه
معسكر فرضه نهم الذي كان في قبضه الحوثيين
ويكتسب اهميه استثنائيه يبعد عن العاصمه
صنعاء نح نحو 30 كترا او يزيد قليلا ويطل
وهذا هو الاهم على قرى بني حشيش وبني
الحارث وارحب نحن هنا على مشارف العاصمه
اذا بعد معارك استمرت شهورا طويله كان
مسرحها يمتد من عدن الى تعز وما بينهما
وكان الظن ان الاستراتيجيه العسكريه تقوم
على التتابع اي محافظه تلو اخرى وصولا الى
صنعاء الياتي الاستيلاء على معسكر فرضه
نهم ليقدم سيناريو بديلا مفاجئا وربما اثر
جدوى سواء من حيث المده الزمنيه المفترضه
للمعارك او مداها وهدفها وفي راي البعض
فان هذا تطور بالغ الدلاله يقوم على
مهاجمه المركز بهدف اضعاف الخصم في
الاطراف وربما دفعه الى الانهيار
فيها وبحسب يمنيين منخرطين في المعارك
فانه ما كان يمكن الوصول الى الحزام
القبلي لصنعاء لولا انشقاق العديد من
الضباط والجنود عن القوات المواليه للرئيس
صالح وال الحوثيين وانضمامهم الى قوات
الشرعيه والمقاومه وهو ما يكتسي اهميه
مضاعفه ويثير خشيه الحوثيين من انقلاب
محتمل في الولاءات داخل قوات صالح نفسها
في هذه المنطقه تحديدا من شان حسم معركه
غلاف صنعاء فرض حقائق على الارض تتعلق بما
هو قبلي وتاليا عسكري
فالبيئة يعني مددا عسكريا اضافيا واطباق
على صنعاء في حال بدات معركتها يعرف ذلك
الرئيس هادي كما تعرفه المقاومه وقوات
التحالف فثم فرصه لتوسيع جبهه المواجهات
في محيط صنعاء وصولا الى ارحب لدفع
الحوثيين الى التراجع اكثر وثمه من يقول
ويرى بان قصفا لمحافظه صعده وتقدما نحو
صنعاء كفيلان بتفكيك الحوثييين وصالح ودفع
قواتهم للانهيار في ضمار واب والبيضاء
وتعز دفعه واحده ذلك هو الراس اذا ضرب
وتاثيره السالب على الاطراف على ما
يقولون موضوع حلقتنا هذا نناقشه مع ضيوفنا
من عمان سمير الحاج المتحدث باسم الجيش
الوطني اليمني ومن اسطنبول ياسين التمامي
المحلل السياسي اليمني ومن صنعاء سوف ينضم
الينا عبر الهاتف عبد الوهاب الشرفي رئيس
مركز رصد الديمقراطيه نرحب بضيوفنا جميعا
وابدا معك استاذ سمير الحاج في
عمان نريد في البدايه بصفتك المتحدث باسم
الجيش الوطني ان تقول لنا ما تعرفونه عن
هذه المعارك في فرضت ن ما الذي يجري
بالضبط شكرا لك اختي خديجه ومشاهدي
الجزيره الاعزاء الحقيقه نحن نستطيع ان
نقول اننا اليوم
بصدد باذن الله تعالى المشهد الاخير
لمعركه دخول
صنعاء وكان ذلك من البوابه الشرقيه طبعا
فرضه نهم بالامس كان هناك تقدم وسيطره على
منطقه فرضه نهم واليوم استكملنا ما تبقى
من جيوب وهناك بعض الاشخاص مختبئين في
جروف في نقطه نهم نفسها ليس لديهم الى
طريقين اما الاستسلام او الموت الان
التقدم ما بعد فرضه نهم نحن نتحدث عن
التقرب من منطقه نقيل غيلان وهذه المنطقه
اذا ما تم السيطره عليها وعلى التباب
المحيطه بها استطيع اقول ان ربما مطار
صنعاء الدولي اصبح تحت مرمى الجيش الوطني
والمقاومه لدينا ايضا هناك التقاء
بالجبهات اليوم التقت جبهه من الجهه
الجنوبيه ا من جبال منيف للفرض ومن
الجهه الشماليه التقط وقطعت الطريق تماما
الخط الرئيسي الواصل بين صنعاء ومارب
والجوف هناك ايضا تقدم من خط مفرق الجوف
صنعاء هذه الجبهه تقريبا الان اصبحت على
وشك استكمال مهامها ننتظر قليلا نظرا
لوجود حق الالغام الكثيفه والعشوائيه التي
زرعت في كل المناطق في هذه الجبال لكي في
انه في منطقه صغيره لا تتجاوز 30 40 متر
تم استخراج اكثر من 20 لغم وهذه ربما تعيق
قليلا احيانا الحركه لدينا الجبهه الاخرى
التي تتحرك باتجاه ميدي والتي سيطرت على
منطقه ميدي وكنا قد تحدثنا عن سيطرتها عن
الميناء وعلى وعلى القلعه اليوم سيطرت على
المدينه وهذا الخط ايضا هو في اتجاه منطقه
حيدان صعده احتمال ان نتحرك في هذا
الاتجاه لغرض الشد الخ نا على منطقتي صعده
وصنعاء طيب ناخذ راي المقاومه الشعبيه من
خلال عبد الله
[موسيقى]
الشندقورة الان المقاومه كما ذكر يعني
المتحدث باسم الجيش العزيز تتقت مقاومه
الجوف بمقاومه صنعاء التحمت المقاومه من
الجهه الجنوبيه باتجاه جبل يام بالجهه
الشماليه التي جاءت من اتجاه ملح
والاتجاه الجنوبي لمنطقه الفرضه التق
المقاومه اليوم في هذه النقطه نقطه
الارتكاز التي تتعدى جبال ومرتفعات فرض
اثنين اليوم المقاومه تجعل فرض ض نهم
خلفها وتتقدم نحو صنعاء باكثر من 5 ك متر
تم السيطره خلال امس واليوم على يعني قريه
النشف وبني زرعا والفرع وايضا تم السيطره
على جبل المدفون وتم السيطره كذلك على
مسوره كل هذه المناطق تقع في الجهه
الغربيه من فرض اثنين طبعا يتبقى بعض
الجيوب داخل معسكر فرض اثنين المعسكر الى
الان تحيط به الق يعني جزء من القوات
المقاومه والجيش الوطني لا يزال في داخل
المعسكر بعض القناصين وبعض الجيوب لايس
لهم الا ان يسلموا انفسهم او يموتوا يعد
هذا المكان بحكم الساقط لان المقاومه
والجيش الوطني قد تعدت باتجاه صنعاء وهي
الان المعارك تدول داخل يعني تعدت مسوره و
تدور المعارك بالاتجاه الغربي من مسوره
وكل هذه المناطق التي هي تعتبر 5 ك م من
الفرضه الى داخل المسوره تم السيطره عليها
ونحن الان في صوب التحرك الى صنعاء ومن
خلال هذا الحدث الذي تم ستتحرك الجبهات
الاخرى التي هي داخل رواع وايضا من الجهات
الغربيه والجنوبيه من اكثر من مسار سيكون
دخول صنعاء لم يتبقى بيننا وبين نقيل بن
غيلان الا عده كيلومترات سنسيطر خلالها
على هذا النقيل الذي هو مرتكز ومكان
استراتيجي وهام يعني تنكشف كثير من
الاهداف الاستراتيجيه لمليشيات داخل امانه
العاصمه منها كما ذكر المطار ومنها ايضا
مواقع اخرى ستكون تحت مرم نيران المقاومه
والجيش الوطني نعم طيب شكرا لك عبد عبد
الله الشانق على هذه التوضيحات فيما يتعلق
بالتحركات الميدانيه اتحول الى عبد الوهاب
الشرفي في صنعاء يعني واضح ان هناك يعني
الظروف تهيئات للتحرك نحو صنعاء بهذا
التقدم الذي تحققه المقاومه الشعبيه
والجيش الوطني كيف ينظر الحوثي وقوات صالح
لهذا
التقدم مساء الخير لك ولضيوفك الكرام
[موسيقى]
وللسادة في هذه النقاط
للفترات تكون امنه وينتقل بمعركه الى نقاط
متقدما
اكثر هذا من جهه وايضا لا يمكن حتى الان
الحديث عن ان هذا الامر يمكن ان يمثل
تدشينا لما يمكن ان نسميه بمعركه صنعاء
على اعتبار انه لازال الخلف لهذه القوات
هناك لازالت كثير من النقاط في الجوف وفي
مارب هي تراوح وضعها السابق لازال هناك
تداخل في المعارك في هذه المحافظات ومن
الطبيعي انه لا يمكن اساسا ان يقدم احد
على ان يدخل معركه صنعاء ما لم يكن قد امن
ظهره ما يحصل كما قلت لك هي انت لو تلاحظي
الوصول الى هذه النقاط لم ياتي نتيجه
عمليات عسكريه متتابعه ومتنقل من نقطه الى
اخرى وانما جاء نتيجه عمليه
التفاف قامت بها هذه القوات ال المواليه
لهذه الى ان وصلت الى هذه النقاط والمساله
متعلقه الان بقضيه الايام القادمه التي
ستجعلنا نحكم على هذا التقدم هل هو عفوا
على هذا الاختراق هل هو تقدم ام انه
اختراق سيلقى نفس مصير الاختراقات التي
حصلت خلال الاسابيع الماضيه والتي تم
الوصول فيها الى مفرق الجوف والجميع لازال
يذكر تلك التقدمات التي انتهت بعد ايام
هذا طيب دعنا نقول هذه الفكره للاستاذ
سمير الحاج قد يكون هذا التقدم تقدما يعني
مرحليا و يعني يحدث تراجع كما حدث في
تقدمات سابقه قد لا يحدث ثبات على هذا
التقدم ولا يمكن البناء عليه والقول انه
تدشين لمعركه صنعاء ما
ردك
ا الاستاذ عبد الوهاب دائما يجيد
ربما اللعب بالالفاظ يعني انا اريد ان
افهم كعسكري ماذا ما هو الفرق بين التقدم
والالتفاف الالتفاف هو خطوه اولى لاجراء
تقدم في اي منطقه من المناطق هذا من جانب
من الجانب العسكري الصرف اما ان نقول ان
هناك التفاف وليس هناك تقدم انا اؤكد بانه
تقدم مدروس ومنضبط ويسير بخطى ثابته
ورغم وجود حقول الالغام المتناثره وهذا
دليل مؤكد على ان الحوثي وصالح لا يفكروا
بالعوده الى هذه المناطق وقد خرجوا منها
منسحبين والا لما قاموا بتلغيم هذه
المناطق كلها وتفخيخ
ومن ثم انا اعتقد انه باذن الله لن يكون
هناك اي انكسار او تراجع للجيش الوطني
واؤكد هنا للجيش الوطني والمقاومه الشعبيه
وليس القوات هاه كما يقول اخي عبد الوهاب
وان شاء الله عما قريب يسقط مشروع
الانقلاب الفوضوي الذي ادخل البلد في هذه
المتاهات
ودمر البلاد والعباد كما يقول وحاصر الناس
واخافه ونعود الى وطن امن باذن الله طيب
استاذ ياسين في اسطنبول نريد ان نفهم ايضا
دور القبائل في هذا التقدم موضوع التركيبه
القبليه الخاصه بحزام صنعاء والدور الذي
تلعبه القبائل في التنسيق مع المقاومه مع
المقاومه والجيش
الوطني بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم تحيه لك
استاذه خديجه ولضيوفك
الكرام من الواضح ان المعارك التي تدور
اليوم في الى الشرق من صنعاء من الاثار
المباشره لهذه المعارك معرك انها حيدت
الحزام القبلي الذي لطالما راهن عليه
الانقلابيون واعتقدوا ان الحزام القبلي هو
جزء من استراتيجيه المواجهه مع الجيش
الوطني واستراتيجيه ابقاء محيط صنعاء
ارضيه صلبه لهذه القوات التي تسيطر على
الدوله منذ سقوط صنعاء في
21/24 من الواضح ان ان المعارك اليوم تدور
في ارضيه مراوغه نوعا ما اذا جاز التعبير
ف
المحيط القبلي هناك يبدو انه دخل مرحله
الحياد الكامل ان لم نقل بان الجزء الاكبر
من التركيبه العشائريه خصوصا في منطقه نهم
هي اصلا محسوبه على المقاومه كما ورد في
التقرير وهذا شيء صحيح فاعتقد ان هذه
القبائل اليوم هي تعمل او وتقاتل لصالح
المقاومه والجيش الوطني
وتقاتل بمعنوي عاليه انها استطاعت الى
جانب الجيش انكار نعم في السابق تم شراء
ولاء هذه القبائل لا
لم هو حدث حدث انكسار كبير بعد 21 سبتمبر
حتى دون شراء ولاءات حدث انكسار لانه
بمجرد سقوط العاصمه صنعاء
انكسرت الشوكه القبليه وهذا كان واحد من
الانجازات اللي هي الثوره المضاده عندما
وضع الرئيس السابق علي عبد الله صالح
والرئيس المخل علي عبد الله صالح امكانيه
القوات المسلحه تحت تصرف ميليشيا ت مثل
ميليشيا الحوثي لكن اليوم انا في تقديري
التحول الكبير هو في كسر التوازن النفسي
في في في طبيعه المعركه التي تدور الى
الشرق من صنعاء الى درجه ان النشوه اليوم
انتقلت بشكل كامل الى الطرف الذي يعادي
الانقلابيين واقصد ب ليس فقط الجيش وانما
المقاومه المقاومه التي تنتمي الى هذه
المناطق والى مناطق اخرى والى مناطق اخرى
كثيره في اليمن لها ثاره على الاقل مع
الحوثيين يقاتلون بمعنويات عاليه وبنفسي
واث
جدا القبائل ايضا اعتقد ان القبائل هم قد
يتم شراء بعض الولاءات بالمال لكن عاده في
تركيب القبليه يمكن ان يخوضوا المعركه
لمرحله ما لكن اذا شعروا ان مغنم ان
خسارتهم في هذه المعارك اقل من المغانم
المتوقعه فعلى طول يتحي دوه ويخرجوا خارج
المعركه وهو ما نراه اليوم انا اعتقد انه
المحيط القبل لصنعاء تحيد بشكل كامل نعم
سوف نبحث بعد الفاصل تاثير هذا الت قدم
على القرار الاستراتيجي المتعلق بالمعركه
الحاسمه معركه صنعاء فلا تذهبوا بعيدا سوف
[موسيقى]
نعود مشاهدينا اهلا وسهلا بكم من جديد الى
هذه الحلقه التي تناقش القرار الاستراتيجي
المتعلقه بمعركه صنعاء مع اقتراب المقاومه
اليمنيه والجيش الوطني من من صنعاء نرحب
بضيوفنا من جديد واستاذ سمير الحاج في
عمان ما تاثير هذا التقدم اذا على القرار
الاستراتيجي المتعلق بمعركه
صنعاء في حقيقه الامر استطيع ان اقول ان
هذا التقدم
ربما بل مؤكد هو في الحقيقه
اصبح الخط الاول لتنفيذ الخيار
الاستراتيجي بالسيطره على العاصمه صنعاء
طبعا لم يكن يتوقع الحوثي ولم يكن يتوقع
صالح ان يكون الزحف من اتجاه الجبهه
الشرقيه كان ربما لديهم فكره ان ربما
ياتيهم من الجبهه الغربيه لكن نظرا لوجود
الحزام القبلي القوي كما قال اخي وصديقي
من اسطنبول لكن الان تاكد استراتيجيا ان
الخط الاقرب للوصول الى العاصمه صنعاء هو
المدخل الشرقي وكما رايتم الجميع تقريبا
القبل الذي كان يراهن عليها علي ص صالح
والحوثي في صد اي تقدم اصبحت اما محايده
او منتظره تقرب القوات حتى تشارك مع
القوات في
ربما دخول صنعاء وال كسر الانقلاب فسترا
جيا يعتبر السيطره على هذا المدخل
والسيطره وخطوه جباره وكبيره في اتجاه
اداره معركه صنعاء واقولها اليوم ان معركه
صنعاء لا نقول انها في البدايه ولكن هي في
مراحلها ربما قبل النهائيه باذن الله طيب
استاذ عبد الوهاب الشرفي اذا كان الحوثيون
اذا محاصرون الان من عده جهات هناك تقدم
بالجوف في الشرق هناك ايضا بمدي في الغرب
والان ب شمال شرق البلاد هذا يعني ان
الحوثيين وقوات صالح محاصرين من عده جهات
هل يمكن القول اذا ان معركه صنعاء مساله
وقت لا
اكثر وبطبع مساله الحصار هي ليست جديده هي
النقاط التي تتحدثي عنها هي نقاط مواجهات
ربما من بدايه المعارك لكن ما قلت انا انه
يحصل كاختراع
حاليا لا يمكن ان نحكم عليه كتقدم حتى
يثبت هذا ابتداء بالنسبه لمعركه صنعاء انا
قلت انه لا اتوقع على الاطلاق ان هناك
قائد عسكري يمكن ان يتخذ قرارا الان ببدء
معركه صنعاء وهو يعرف ان ظهره في الخلف لم
ليس مؤمنا حتى الان ا هذه الاخراجات ك ليس
مؤمنا لا زالت هناك المسائل في الجوف لم
تسيطر عليها الان قوات هذه سيطره كامله
مارب ايضا لم تسيطر عليها لازال هناك اكثر
من نقطه من النقاط وهي ربما ان هذ
هذه الاختراقات التي تحصل هي ذات علاقه
بمارب وبجوف اكثر من علاقتها بصنعاء في
هذه المرحله بمعنى انه يحاول الان ان يقطع
خطوط الامدادات ويحاول ان يتمركز في مواقع
استراتيجيه معينه تمكنه من ان يحسم
المسائل في الجوف وفي مارب وليس وليسوا
الان في طور الحديث عن معركه صنعاء على كل
حال هو يظل مساله الخطوره هي قائمه لا
يمكن ان يتم الاستهانه بهذه الاختراقات
التي حصلت لكن في الاخير يجب ان نراعي
نقطه متمثله في
ان التفوق بالنسبه لسلاح الجو الذي لا تجد
قوات اللجان الشعبيه هنا
اي يعني مكافحا له او ما تستطيع ان ترد به
هي يعني تتحول الى قضيه الاخلاء نعم لكن
لكن خل خلينا نرجع الى نعود الى نقطتنا
الرئيسيه هل هناك تجهيزات استعدادات لدى
الحوثي تهبا ربما احتياطا لما قد يحدث من
تقدم نحو العاصمه صنعاء في الايام القادمه
هو بالطبع لابد الان ان يكون التعزيز في
ذلك الاتجاه جاري على كذا من الوساق لانه
كما قلت لك المسائل هي تظل تدخل مرحله
الخطوره يعني ما حصل هو اختراق نوعي وليس
اختراق عادي وبالتالي لابد ان تعزز تلك
الجبهات وهناك
ايضا يعني محاولات لاستنهاض المجتمع على
اعتبار ان الدخول
ال ما يسمى بالمقاومه هو محمولا على مركب
العدوان الذي ينظر اليه قدر كبير من
المجتمع بعدم القبول لما الحكه بالبلد من
خسائر بالمدنيين ربما تفوق الخسائر في
العسكريين هذا
الجانب يعني لا هو المفترض الطبيعي الان
ان يتم مساله الحشد والاعداد والتجهيز في
ذلك الاتجاه بقدر اكبر من الماضي ياسين
تميمي في اسطنبول الطريق نحو العاصمه من
بوابتها الشرقيه بات مفتوحا
برايك الطريق بات مفتوحا انا في تقديري ان
ما يراه عليه الاخ عبد الوهاب الشرفي او
ما اشار اليه هو مبالغ فيه الى حد كبير
انا اعتقد ان الجبهه الخلفيه للانقلابيين
واقصد بها مدينه صنعاء هي جبهه اعتقد انها
موتوره ومحتقر
ببقاء الانقلابيين اكثر يعني مما بقت في
صنعاء وبهذا هنا اعتقد ان المعادله يمكن
ان تحسب لحساب لصالح المقاومه والجيش
الوطني هو اشار الى قضيه التغطيه الجويه
التغطيه الجويه هي تصل الى صنعاء كل يوم
وتحدث صدمه وترويع كبير جدا وهذا
بالحسابات العسكريه اعتقد انه يؤثر على
معنويات الوحدات العسكريه
والميليشيا المرابطه في في صنعاء وبالتالي
في تقديري ان حاجز الصد الوحيد الذي كان
يراهن عليه الحوثيون وقوات المخلوع صالح
وهو الفرضه نهم سقط كما سقطت حواجز صط مهم
صد مهمه واكثر اهميه في محافظه مارب اعتقد
انه لا مفاجات ولا خط ماجينو لدى الحوثيين
وقوات المخلوع صالح يمكن ان يعيق تقدم
القوات قوى الجيش الوطني وبالتالي انا في
تقديري انه الخط سالك اجتماعيا الخط سالك
اقتصاديا الخط سالك عسكريا الخط سالك
نفسيا الخط سالك
الم الجيش الوطني بصنعاء نعم اعود الى
سمير الحاج يعني عبد الوهاب الشرفي قال
ظهركم مكشوف ما زالت هناك جيوب في الجوف
وفي مارب وفي مناطق اخرى كيف الذهاب يمكن
الذهاب الى صنعاء و ظهركم غير مؤمن كما
قال وهذا كما يقال من اغرب الغرائب القوه
تتقدم بكامل عتادها وتخترق المناطق وتصل
الى فرضه نهم وظهرها مكشوف نحن كعسكري
نستغرب مثل هذا الحديث لانه لا يمكن ان
تتقدم القوات وظهرها مكشوف لا يوجد اي
نقاط واي اي قوه للحوثي في مارب الان بل
حتى في الجوف الان وصلت الى حدود الخط
الرئيسي الدولي في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه لا يوجد اي نقاط الان خلف القوات
يمكن ان تؤثر على سير القوات هذا حقيقه
حديث ملتبس غير دقيق القوه تسير بشكل
ممتاز وظهرها مؤمن تماما وليس يعني هناك
ما يثير اي قلق لديها ايضا تسير بخطا
عسكريه مرتبه ومنظمه يقودها رئاسه الاركان
ويقودها يعني القاده الميدانيين اعتقد ان
هذا الحديث فقط ربما لاعاده رفع معنويات
المليشيات حتى تصمد اكثر شكرا لك سمير
الحاج المتحدث باسم الجيش الوطني اليمني
من عمان وشكرا ايضا للاستاذ ياسين التميمي
من اسطنبول المحلل السياسي اليمني وايضا
نشكر من صنعاء الاستاذ عبد الوهاب الشرفي
رئيس مركز رصد الديمقراطي وكان معنا في
الجزء الاول من البرنامج عبد الله الشدقي
المتحدث الرسمي باسم المقاومه الشعبيه
بهذا تنتهي حلقتنا من برنامج ما وراء
الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في قراءه جديده في
م وراء خبر جديد لكم منا اطيب المناى والى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء
ه